[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
video game leaks and rumors are usually
fake right
like that time insomniac were rumored to
be making a ps4 spider-man game and we
once thought the next tomb raider game
would be called shadow of the tomb
raider
because some dude had a laptop on a
train wait a sec both of these were
right
well there's one game series with more
leaks and rumors than any other
grand theft auto and today we're going
to go through all the reputable leaks
about
gta 6. there are a ton here let's come
back in a year's time to see if we knew
all about gta 6 before we officially
knew about gta 6.
first up and most recently a patent from
rockstar games parent company take 2
interactive
issued back in 2019 suddenly popped up
on reddit and it's almost certainly
related to gta 6
with the catchy title system and method
for virtual navigation in a gaming
environment
snappy title right this document
highlights a method of getting improved
ai
from limited hardware let's break it
down a bit
in a huge city like los santos there are
thousands of npcs going about their
business
in games like cyberpunk the npcs walk
aimlessly back and forth
which is pretty much the same thing that
happened in the ps one days
recently though watchdog's legion
slightly improved this
by giving jobs and schedules to
characters who would get up in a morning
go to work and then return home at the
end of the day it wasn't massively
sophisticated but it did add more depth
than we usually used to
in gta 6 this will be improved again
with ai that understands the rules of
the road
not only waiting at stop signs and
traffic lights but actively avoiding
collisions and defining their own way to
travel from a to b
and we can impact them as players right
now in many games
npc drivers will attempt to get out of
our way if we get too close
in gta 6 these guys are so intelligent
that they will re-plan their entire
route to their destination
based on that interaction so for example
if there is a huge piece of carnage on
the end of the road the npcs will replan
their route to their destination
avoiding this area completely could be
cool
[Music]
officially gta 6 has not been confirmed
at all
yet in march 2020 one of the actors
accidentally confirmed the existence of
the game
in his online resume jorge conseco
sorry if i butchered that name conseco
cv lists his tv
film and theater history and look in
2018
he completed cgi work for rockstar games
for a little unknown title named grand
theft auto 6.
the internet went wild and mr c quickly
deleted the role from the document
and offered this explanation instead
dear friends
while i read every message from you
please know that because of contract
stipulations sometimes i'm unable to
comment on certain projects
please don't feel ignored or unseen i
appreciate and value
every single one of you and to rub salt
in the wound he gave cheeky replies to
gta fans
which all but confirmed the role welcome
to the world of nda's non-disclosure
agreements
make things like this seem like
conspiracy theories
look at the name of the character the
mexican we have no idea if this is a
legitimate name
maybe a low-level character without a
name or maybe a key character
we will need to wait for answers but
this looks like solid evidence that gta
will have a mexican
not a mexican
another thing this confirms is that
mocap for gta 6
began and maybe ended in 2018 and it's
now 2021
so can we conclude the game is halfway
to completion
maybe even more others working on the
project have leaked info which again
confirms the existence of the game
the stuntman who regularly works with
rockstar tim neth
uploaded a picture of a mocap session
from inside rockstar san diego
and quickly then deleted it after
receiving gta questions
he then confirmed this all again via his
online cv
it's gta 6 and yep it's been deleted
from his resume again
tim went on to tell everyone this wasn't
true and he wasn't working on red dead
redemption 2
or gta 6 and lo and behold in the red
dead redemption 2 credits
it's tim and even a vehicle designer
from india let slip that they are
working on gta 6
after completing work on huge games like
forza i think that's enough evidence to
confirm gta is real and in development
right now
here's an interesting piece of info back
in may 2019 via a glass door review
for those that don't know glassdoor is a
recruitment company who allow reviews of
the companies they represent
one is very interesting indeed one
disgruntled employee a qa tester in
edinburgh scotland
gave rockstar a three out of five review
noting crunch time working hours and a
bullying culture
but it wasn't all doom and gloom they
got to play the ps5 early in 2019
i know people in 2021 who still can't
find a ps5
the post includes a feedback section
aimed at management to help them improve
their organization
but get this read the first letter of
each line
gta 6 ls vc
lc we'll expand that a bit grand theft
auto 6
los santos vice city liberty city
it's too perfect to be a coincidence so
what could this mean
los santos is the la of the gta world in
which we recently changed our yiyas
haircut liberty city was where we went
bowling with family
and by city was the location set back in
the 1980s
in a miami-esque location and your mom's
favorite drummer came to stay
is the qa tester saying all these three
locations will be available in gta 6
well we can delve into another potential
leak for answers
after the internet decided to target
rockstar for poor working conditions and
crunch culture
it was revealed this would be key to
their future plans
or at least it would be tested kotaku
reported in april 2020 that gta 6 would
likely be smaller than a typical
rockstar games game
with a new focus on adding new locations
at regular intervals
see where i'm going with this let's go
back to the glass door clue
it's basically telling us gta 6 will
take place in multiple locations
just as the kotaku article infers over a
year later
starting us off in one location before
adding others later in the game's
development cycle
not only would this make for the game to
be available quicker it would also save
the devs from a great deal of crunch
culture
and also confirms future content to keep
us all playing instead of falling off
the game and moving on
this business model could be good for
everyone
[Music]
let's go back to 2019 for the next info
hunt
and the secret title of project americas
giving a game a mystery title is key to
keeping things under wraps
psvr was called project morpheus after
the god of dreams
the gamecube was named project dolphin
due to the ability to render water
physics in a new way
and the connect was known as project
natal which google tells me relates to
buttocks okay so some names link up
perfectly with their intended use
and others are about butts project
americas has been dropped in multiple
articles regarding gta 6 for years now
and suggests the game once again will
have multiple locations
gta will venture out of the usa and into
south america and hey that would
perfectly tie into mr conseco's resume
earlier on
see things are starting to line up this
wouldn't be the first time rockstar has
ventured outside the money-spinning
world of the usa
the original red dead had elements in
mexico and more recently this was tested
in red dead redemption 2
no less with a linear mission set on the
desert island of guama
which looks to me a lot like the islands
around haiti and cuba
if i had to guess all this info has led
to brazil
or colombia being outlined as locations
insert your favorite you're going to
brazil meme here please
brazil is actually a location that
rockstar have visited in person and
taken
extensive scans and research of any max
payne fans in the house
max payne 3 saw rockstar games take over
from the original devs remedy
and took the bullet-time marksmanship of
max to brazil
a huge change from new jersey and right
now we live in a time where
international travel
isn't a great idea well it's a good
thing that rockstar already has all
their wreckies images and assets
needed to make a brazilian location
let's keep this going forward let's look
at the most convincing of rumors and
leaks from a chap on reddit no less
yeah i know already isn't worth your
time and trust but stick with it it's
interesting i promise
jackolanton1982 who is almost 40 if that
name is accurate
gave us a ton of information about
project americas
get your eyes and ears around this in
one section they talk about the game
being heavily inspired by netflix's
narcos series
for those that don't know that show is
centered around the very real drug
kingpin pablo escobar
during the 1980s he was responsible for
most of the drug distribution in the usa
and south america
this leak states the game is based on
these events starting in the 1970s and
80s
using the same empire building as in
vice city stories
and then as time passes the city will
evolve and change
just like those towns in red dead
redemption 2. and this thread also
states that both the usa and south
american locations will be utilized
so multiple leaks from multiple sources
are claiming very similar things
and then i saw this point a younger
martin madrazo will make an appearance
as will his father who is a big drug
lord at the time
we will do some missions for the madrazo
family involving hits on other gangs
here's the bit that blew my mind this
was written over two years ago
and now look at gta online right now and
the new guy's ko perico
who should turn up in this mission it's
only martin madrazo's wife
and son a coincidence i think not
this is either a case of the leaker
accidentally revealing the heist and not
gta 6
or if we think bigger rockstar could be
linking together the stories of all the
games
bringing everything together of course
the original post was deleted from
history
but not before multiple outlets took the
info and made it accessible
forever and wait there's more recently
in the red dead redemption 2 files
a set of guns were found which didn't
line up with the wild west era
the ak-47 and the l1a1 of course we know
these guns weren't a thing when john
marston was around
but coincidentally they were very
accessible in the 80s
which once again links to gta 6 being
set in the 1980s
these guns within red dead 2 led people
to question if rockstar were testing gta
6
in the new rage engine there are a ton
more supposed leaks and rumors but i
thought these were the most reliable and
informative
there's actually a really cool one in
the airport there are two doors side by
side
one reads 2013 and the other reads 2021
gta 5 was released in 2013 so is this
door telling us that gta 6 will be
arriving in 2021
i think that's wishful thinking but it's
it's a cool coincidence all the same
isn't it so to end let's link everything
from this video
into one idea according to the
questionable leaks
gta 6 will be a multi-location story of
a thug who rises up
inside a drug cartel in colombia or
brazil
to become a kingpin in both the usa and
south america
over decades their story will be told
across vice city liberty city
los santos and more okay gta 6
take my money i'm adam from playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you